Joannie Boselli is joining us a lead
analyst for Thursday Night Football
Westwood One five-time Pro Bowler and
kind enough to join us after a late
night good morning Tony how are you I'm
doing well are you guys what's the most
you ever ate that is sitting that's a
great questions listen I got hungry
thinking four pounds of ribs like I
think I could easily down four pounds of
ribs I do not think that would be
difficult but did you ever have the
offensive lineman who got in like when
you guys get together you don't want to
have somebody's fingers get in the way
of you guys you guys know I wouldn't
gone ribs I would never go ribs with a
bunch of offensive linemen I got ribs
with my wife who and my kids who not
mighty I wouldn't take my sons because
they might get my way you know you go
off into line like a steak where you get
your own plate of food and you manage
manage that yourself there's too many
things going on with ribs on the table
did you have a hard time putting on
weight or taking off weight I can do
both really effectively and I was an all
seriousness I was lucky playing I could
you know I weighed 325 every day of my
life just about regardless of what I ate
you know I gotta go up to 327 I eat a
little bit less I got 323 a little bit
more but I was around that weight all
the time and and now I have the ability
to fluctuate by much greater amounts
last night not close and personal with
this it looked like it was gonna be a
great game a shootout and then all of a
sudden Pittsburgh hit an extra gear and
then it was over but what what stood out
if you're a Carolina Panther fan what
should you be concerned about
even though Ron Rivera said it's just
one game you saw what last night that
would concern you the rest of the season
well the pass rush that would be
concerning for me and I was and Addison
they they don't have a consistent pass
rush so I mean I think that's the one
biggest thing which then you know makes
you pretty vulnerable in the past you
know in the secondary if you're not
rushing the passer in today's rules
outside I mean I think they're gonna be
fine the offensive line they gave up
some pressure to which they haven't been
doing for the when they've been playing
well but yeah I think they're gonna be
fine I actually agree with Ron Rivera I
said it design Eagle after the game we
did a wrap-up I said if I'm Ron Rivera
locker room and say we're forgetting
about this right now it's an anomaly
where we're good football team because
they are you know
okay I'm slanted the highest level he's
done in a long time as far as
efficiencies I think more curves did a
great job
I love Christian McCaffrey I think he is
an outstanding - way back in the young
receivers that you know that are
starting to play better and more and
samuels I think they're gonna be fine
now I don't think the problem with the
Carolina Panthers I don't think they're
good enough to beat the Saints and so
you're really playing for a wild-card
spot in the NFC as far as the Steelers
now we see this and then we act
surprised that we see it but we
shouldn't be surprised when they have
the offenses clicking and you know last
night Ben had one of those nights but
are they going to be consistent enough
offensively the rest of the year yeah I
think offensively they're gonna be fine
that's not their problem down the
stretch even the last few years and we
look at the playoffs last year where Jax
will beat them they'd be in like 40 to
35 yeah doctor they don't score enough
points it's the defense lets them down
in big moments and it's in particular
that secondary they say they have to the
front floor gonna have to play great the
rest of the year Joe Hayden he's playing
well in the back half and they got some
nice pieces but it's really the front
floor if they can get the pass rush out
of bud Dupree in TJ water on the outside
and then to it and Hayward inside those
four they can pressure with fourth then
they'll be fine
but offensively I don't worry about them
one bit I mean they have weapons
everywhere James Conner filling I mean
the real interesting thing is gonna be
what they do with levy on bail if he
does sign which I can't imagine him not
I mean he's already thrown away enough
money if I were the starting tackle on
the Steelers would you want lady on bail
in there yes come on Dan I want less
all-pro players and more no yes I want
my my team Oh show up I don't care I
don't care why you held out I don't care
what you did if you show up and you can
help me win I want you on my team now if
you're a distraction and you become a
problem the locker room then no we're
just I'll deactivate you and get rid of
you but until you prove differently I
want you on my team he's a great player
I wouldn't start him I think it's James
Connors job but here's what people
forget levy on bail can be your third
receiver he can play the slot
and so I want them immediately please
come back okay here's my only concern
about that is you know does he say
you're using me too much if this is all
about I want to protect myself and get
that next contract here what's gonna
stop him from saying hey hi I don't want
to play an overtime or you know what
you're giving me too many touches here
well that's when he becomes a
distraction you get rid of them but
until that happens I play up stop
yelling at me Tony you're yelling at me
why in 24 hours and you asked me when
the last time you asked think like an
offensive lineman to somebody I mean
that offensive lineman's perspective I'm
trying to get you in the Hall of Fame I
know listen you're one of my favorite
people in the media and it started last
year when someone shot me a text and you
know damn Patrick's trying to get you in
the hall family said well you know what
he is now my favorite radio show on
there well I I got Terrell Davis in and
I worked hard for that and I worked hard
for Jack Morris to get into the Baseball
Hall of Fame and you know what I don't
think people realize how great you were
they might not remember but I hope they
do but you know I know the injuries but
yeah I hope you get into the Hall of
Fame I do I appreciate it I appreciate
that
I do I really appreciate you'll be a
great honor all right and you don't have
to mention me in the speech all right
okay no I have no problem mentioning the
people who helped me I mean you'd be one
of them my friend good friends from CBS
beep riscos out there babe banging the
drums is where I'll mention him there's
a few I'll mention out there but they're
not a lot well I might be presenting you
so you wouldn't have to thank dan
Patrick my son Mark Brunell
or Dan Patrick it's a tough decision
best team in the AFC right now is it's
the Patriots why because there's vans
because of oh they're going exaction say
that they have two losses the Chiefs
have one I think at the end they'll have
home field if they don't it's the cheats
so whatever between the Chiefs and the
Patriots who give who gets the home
field throughout the playoffs of the
best team and I did I'm betting on Tom
Brady he's remarkable the town Josh
Gordon signing if he's can keep his head
on straight was amazing he's a great
receiver in Bill Belichick I have no
idea how he does it
they don't have the talent on defense
you know on paper yeah they start off
slow every year and then by the end of
it they're playing really good defense
he's a master I give him ton of credit
so Tom Brady's you know is the greatest
ever play the game of my opinion and
because that I go with them first and
foremost best team in the NFC all right
thanks
because I don't think anyone going to
Superdome beat them yeah I think you can
go I think they're get a bowl but you
know what I like them going to the Super
Bowl so you know I I hope that they are
able to do that but you know the Rams
got that the Rams defense I'm still
waiting to figure that out like is it
gonna be formidable or is it just going
to be like sort of complementary I think
it's just not venery because the problem
is is that the SEC back hats not playing
great you know and to leave with that
foot we rank or whatever it is we're not
sure when he's gonna come back in the
front
Aaron Donald's the only guy who can make
a play and so I mean you slide him every
time you double I'm he's still gonna get
a sack or two it's fine but the rest of
the defense in my opinion just okay they
traded for Dante Fowler he was here in
Jacksonville I don't think that's gonna
make a huge difference now they can
score a lot of points and Dan here's the
deal you know those you guys talk about
every day the way this league is set up
and the rules have positioned it where
you might just have to outscore
everybody and if that's the case the
Rams are position pretty well if I said
you could block JJ Watt khalil Mac or
von Miller Miller is the best pass road
pass rushers out of those three my
opinion okay but who would you have a
hard time or you know it's late maybe
one of them who gave you trouble give me
the most row of my entire career
Ali played him once and they only played
defensive end for one year he was a
defensive tackle the rest of his career
and that's John Randle
because Randle was short powerful and
quick and fast let me so I could never
fight the one game I played him was up
in Minnesota I couldn't hear a name
thing and I never feel like I got any
leverage on him because he was always
underneath me and I felt like I was
playing catch-up the entire game so he
would be that and then you know so you
know Michael McCreary from Baltimore's a
great player he played with leverage you
know he was a big you know good player
obviously Bruce Smith I played against
was outstanding player platings they're
late they're Thomas he was good there's
no I mean those are everyone knows those
but yeah I mean the guys that you
wouldn't think of because John Randle
didn't play defensive end except for one
year and Michael McQuarrie because no
one talks about him I'm not great on
those great Baltimore defenses like they
should so those are a couple of them but
the three guys you mentioned of great
players
I just think Von Miller is the best pass
rusher JJ Watt you know you know the
interesting thing about JJ Watt I always
I mean so impressed with them and
especially before he got hurt and he's
come back this year and he still he's
playing at a high level but if you watch
him he's more of a finesse player for a
big guy he is oh he's great with a swim
move great with his hands he does not
power rush people a lot and I think that
it surprises people because everyone
plays the power with them and so they
get caught lean in and and he is such a
great athlete so they each have their
own strengths and in their great you
know to be a great pass rusher you have
to have you have to have a great counter
and each of them have great counters you
can't be just a fastball pitcher because
sooner or later a good offensive tackle
can sit on the fastball you gotta be
able to change it up and each of those
guys can do that they may talk trash to
you you know not I mean I remember that
go back to John Randle that was his MO
yeah I always thought that you know
Bruce was never didn't like me very much
he was not you never had kind words to
share with me on the field Bruce Smith
thank you much I don't determine holding
and eaters either we're all official
doesn't they didn't throw the flag so no
I was not any you know those
here's the one thing the great players
like that if they're not getting to the
quarterback they start talking to get
pressure to ever apologize to your
quarterback is he's down on the ground
dude like when your guy got past you no
no no no I didn't because he didn't
apologize went through a pair used to
tell Marcus Barkin I used to drive work
all the time and I said mark listen
anybody can sit back there when it's
seven on seven and there's no they're
not getting it I mean the real test if
you're a good quarterback is you're
getting smoked in the chin and you're
still completing the ball so you know
everyone somewhere I gotta let a guy go
to test those guys back you need some
sleep I probably do I probably do but
thanks for having me on the show and I
do appreciate the kind words you say
about my career it does mean a lot to me
good luck Tony thank you I'll try not to
yell at you next time that's Tony
Boselli lead analyst Thursday Night
Football in Westwood one five-time Pro
Bowler with the Jags for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]